rich Lerner the golf channel joining us
here once again on the Rich Eisen show
he's at Augusta as part of Golf
Channel's golf central live from the
Masters coverage Hawaii rich doing great
rich over you am I reading too much into
that of him saying I'm talking about
green Jack I'm talking about well maybe
my first reaction wasn't her Tiger say
that even when he had the chip yet a
couple of years ago and that was his
default answer because he thought that's
what people wanted to hear that that's
who Tiger was second place sucks going
all the way back to 1998 I'm here to win
when we know a couple of years ago if he
said that we didn't believe it and he
didn't believe it I think the difference
is now he knows he's good again that's
the key and the evidence is there to
support that in the past was done
talking to three years ago some of those
failed comebacks the evidence to support
Tiger saying he was there to win just
wasn't was legitimate
it is now based on the way he's played
in the run-up to the Masters so how real
is this how it's real it's real he's
killing the golf ball and the biggest
surprise is his short game is back you
typically don't recover from from what
he was going through some have hesitated
to call it chip yes whatever that was a
couple of years ago typically nearing
the age of 40 you just don't recover
from that I I think whatever happened in
May we we saw that it appears as though
that was a wake-up call a bottoming out
she got healthy and III think it was
more than than simply fusing the back
pain management gone wrong is a very
serious issue in this country Tiger has
chosen not to speak about that at length
that's but his decision entirely
whatever the case he appears to be
healthy again and I mean healthy of a
body mind and spirit and so yes I think
this is this is real it was real
Bay Hill it was real at Honda it was
real in Tampa and he's rattling cages
again and he's you know he's moving the
circus again you know the whole
choreography changes when when he's
relevant you know that the media the the
fans and what III think is is sobering
for the younger players whom I love and
have been great for the game but what I
think has to be sobering and I don't
think necessarily they spend a lot of
time thinking about it the way we do but
but this idea that millions of Americans
have emphatically stated we're not
interested in watching you Jordan or
Jason or Justin or Dustin we're only
interested in watching Tiger now we've
known that in golf for a long time no
Tiger we have a wonderful passionate
audience a core audience when he's good
that audience doubles triples quadruples
so nobody has has relative to their
sport move the needle as dramatically as
Tiger Woods has in golf and I would
include LeBron or any of the other great
athletes and any other sport and then I
think you know on top of it you you have
you know the possibility that on Sunday
night will will be you know debating
greatest comebacks in sports history and
and it's I think it's a fair you know I
don't want to crown him champion just
yet I mean you know audience size aside
Dustin Johnson Justin Thomas Jordan
speith are not playing around these guys
can really go Rory McIlroy can really go
and they're all peaking they're verging
and it's all converging so Tiger is
going to do it he's going to have to
play great golf I think he's capable of
that and then then we can have the
discussion and if you want I have you
know I have a few few ideas on where to
come back would rank or at least what
other people would
in that conference rich Lerner you have
the floor what do you think well
hopefully I think you know in golf he
obviously you have to look at Hogan
and Tiger did mention Ben Hogan
yesterday nineteen forty five forty nine
I was hit by a bus and he almost died
blood clots in his legs a broken ankle
broken rib and and then he came back
after that accident to win six of his
nine majors the other golfer that that's
forgotten is the great babe Zaharias she
was an all-around athlete and the babe
had colon cancer and had to have surgery
and 14 months later won the US Women's
Open in 1954 by 12 shots that's how
great babe Zaharias was but then you
want to look to other sports simply for
in sort of the depths from which they
had to crawl back Greg Lomond
people probably don't remember but he
was actually shot with sixty pellets on
a hunting trip he lost sixty five
percent of his blood he came back to the
sport with 35 pellets still in his body
and he won two of his three Tour de
France titles that's come back Tommy
John 168 games after the elbow surgery
which was named for him here's a sneaky
one Andre Agassi he was addicted to
crystal meth his marriage to Brooke
Shields was coming apart
he had risk problems he had fallen to
141 in the world he came back and won
five of his eight majors Peyton Manning
had neck surgery came back from that to
win an MVP in a Super Bowl
Mario Lamia would be the last one I
would throw in lymphoma and came back
from that to win a scoring title so I
don't want you know people to get the
idea that in golf where we're so narrow
minded that the Tigers the only one who
faced issues we know that that's not the
case but Tiger had really serious issues
and and he's fairly advanced here in his
career he's 42 so yeah I mean I don't
know that I'm ready to pronounce it the
greatest but but but yes it would be it
would be an all-time you know and
obviously rich what do you think well
obviously no no rich look I don't really
like going there because I want it to
happen so badly why do you want it to
happen and do you think do you think the
public given that all the tiger Spencer
do you think the public wants this to
happen
rich rich of the numbers of the Valspar
or just speak to speak to whether the
public wants to see it and by the way is
that a real bird that we're hearing in
the background because we always thought
it was pumped in are you popping in your
bird sound for this interview we're at
Augusta Country Club they bring you're
just the country clubs has their real
that's great I love it
but yeah I mean of the numbers for the
Valspar just show you how people want it
the reason why I wanted is this rich is
because I remember what Tiger was like
and I do remember what it meant for golf
and the Valspar numbers in the numbers
for Bay Hill etc are showing a different
generation what it was like and it's so
rare for one generation to be seen for
one generation to see what another
generation wants that generation to see
I've got a nine and a seven year old and
a four year old the four year old
doesn't really know much it's good but
then the nine and seven know who Tiger
Woods is and they're running in they're
running in from a different room because
of Tiger Woods and and they did not do
that with all due respect for all the
other players that you mentioned so
you've told your nine and seven year
olds about tag damn straight and what do
you tell him I tell them he's gonna
leave this guy yeah
I tell him he's one of the greatest ever
and what he ever used to do and he's
somebody that broke barriers certainly
in terms of what he looks like and
certainly in terms of how he played and
and then he went away and I really
didn't get really deep deep into you
know the opioid crisis or you know
whatever happened on that Thanksgiving
night but I tell them that this is
incredible what we're seeing potentially
absolutely 1000% so I'm excited for it
rich and I think I think I think in
general you know a nice that you're
sharing that with with your kids who
couldn't have seen the 97 masters or the
2000 years
so from which he won by like 15 shots I
think our generation just had this
desire to see him play the way he once
did he didn't for a week because as good
as these guys are and I mentioned the
group of players no one touches what he
did not not even close and I would just
just throw out that this number Justin
Thomas won five times last year that's a
once in a 20-year kind of season on the
PGA Tour
jordan Spieth in 2015 won five times and
a couple of majors Tiger Woods won five
or more in a season ten freakin times
you're talking about a mind-blowing
level of consistent greatness you know
and I would say this too that the
difference between never has the gap let
me say it this one ever has the gap
between the best in their sport and
everybody else chasing Ben as wide as it
was when Tiger was at the peak of his
powers and I would say that would have
been in 2000 at Pebble Beach when he he
won a US Open by two touchdowns and a
two-point conversion by 15 shots so
these Tigers at Pebble Beach and Ernie
Els and Phil Mickelson and Vijay Singh
and David Duval are in a raft somewhere
close to Australia they're not close so
we have this kind of you know it's
really exciting now I mean you have 1012
guys that are really capable this is
ground but but back then back then
it was only him only him an event the
fact that it could be him again
is I mean understand it's um it's
incredibly exciting but then rich
throw-in Mickelson into this I mean
Mickelson's 47 if Tiger were not here
think help how big the Mickelson story
would be coming in off a win in Mexico
two World Golf Championship 47 a chance
to become the oldest champion
ever at the Masters me Nicholas has had
that distinction for 32 years and
Mickelson's real as real as Tiger is
Nicholson's
legit right now British really playing
well rich I look forward to it and again
your golf central live coverage from the
Masters can be seen on Golf Channel
throughout the week appreciate the time
enjoy the time thanks to the call enjoy
rich feedback that's rich Lerner Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience